[Musique]
n'hésitez pas à parler ça tourne
pourquoi l'absurde pourquoi l'absurde
pourquoi tu fais et pourquoi tu dis ça
tu mens la ques parce que c'est un choix
conscient pour faire rire les gens
pourquoi faire de l'humour bah je sais
pas parce que c'est chiant la vie sans
humour je ne sais pas pourquoi
pourquoi non mais on fait vraiment une
interview sérieux de toi alors parce que
vois-tu la géologie souffre d'une image
particulièrement terne auprès du grand
public et des scientifiques des autres
domaines et pour moi c'est important un
peu de casser cette image est de montrer
que la géologie ça pourrait être cool et
à des fois donc j'ai des géologues qui
me contactent en disant c'est bien c'est
vrai on se reconnaît dans tes vidéos
parce que c'est drôle comme ça et je
leur dis non c'est pas possible non mais
voilà du coup j'essaie de tromper les
gens pour qu'ils aillent ruiner leur vie
d'étudiant hockey et toi pourquoi
pourquoi un tel sex-appeal abbas à ses
demandes à mes parents non moi j'ai une
vraie question
une vraie question piège que je sais pas
de poser en vrai pourquoi cette
obsession pour les nouveaux formats
pourquoi tu veux toujours créer des
nouveaux formats
j'ai pas on se fait chier non sur
youtube un peu assis non déjà on se fait
chier je trouve sur youtube créativement
c'est peu de gens se sortent les doigts
je tombe dans le terme de format n'agit
pas il est allé nager toupie puis à la
bibliothèque
tu vas tu changes les livres non voilà
sinon je m'ennuie quoi le nouveau sujet
c'est cool mais jean une le phare de
toute façon différente et puis non mais
ça c'est je m'ennuie et puis même si je
passe tu regardes tes anciennes vidéos
des fois non mais attendez je serai un
thé en scène vide elle c'est vrai enfin
moi je les fais là récemment pour une
vidéo parce que je me fais traiter un
sujet qui est assez proche je me suis
dit tiens qu'est ce que j'ai racontée
sur le cycle et youtube là est vraiment
sais d'où je trouve pas ce que tu vois
que les hommes mais surtout si tu vois
les les choix qui ont été faits est-ce
que ça intéresse les gens tu as des
retours là dessus sur les formes à ce
que je vois enfin je connais tellement
de gens qui regardent les vidéos sans
les voir en fait qui bouscule ouais ce
qu'il préfère c'est parce qu'on regarde
avec le coeur non je crois qu'au
contraire c'est plutôt nocifs
les formats ça coûte cher à produire
les gens ça peut les sous les codes
théâtraux de montage dit plus ça que tu
vois pourquoi tu fais du mal alors j'ai
envie d'explorer des trucs là là c'est
peut-être un peu égoïste c'est peut-être
aussi un petit hôtel si j'ai envie
d'essayer de pousser le truc genre le
prochain épisode
il sera sorti ma vidéo sera diffusée
mais c'est un ménage c'est grâce à
raquettes oui c'est un monologue
je me suis inspiré d'un épisode de but
jake hoffman oui il fait un monologue
devant le cercueil de sa mère
et que j'y trouvais trop cool et moi
j'ai pas des histoires aussi
intéressante à raconter que beau jake
hoffman mais j'ai fait un beau couple
cours mais c'était un genre [ __ ] pour
faire un truc ya pas inquiète d'asie et
six mois je pense que ça va être des
jeux pour moi c'est très douloureux mais
voilà parce que j'ai envie d'essayer des
trucs quoi et j'ai enregistré six fois
genre avec le prompteur et c'est un
métier ouais pas forcer les gens à bord
du terrain
non même si on est le professionnel tu
vas quand même des youtuber mois les
toits les placements de produits
heineken c'est pourquoi et badens cpn
mais d'autres publient malawi
non par contre j'ai très envie d'aller
démarcher des marques convient d'avoir
genre une marque de paix qu une marque
de jambon vraiment roundup
je vais approcher cochonou bientôt j'ai
redit que j'ai envie de faire ça parce
que c'est drôle c'est surtout de la tune
en fait que le vrai problème c'est la
satisfaction pas maintenant le vrai
problème c'est parce que c'est
effectivement il ya que les avantages
quasiment à faire un truc qui est charte
et si bien que la télé fait ça nous
avons atteint format il le surexploite
pendant 20 ans ces bouteilles qui sont
contre
je n'ai pas d'eau non m haies mais du
coup parce que c'est efficace tu gagnes
tu ne te de machin tout et pas l'un
automatise un peu le système soit pas
soit repensé à chaque fois quoi
exactement impute à des gens qui peuvent
travailler et du coup tu peux déléguer
du coup de tête peu moins travailler et
profiter de toyota voit ça c'est cool
c'est ce qu'on avait il ya des
entreprises où nous les youtube heures
mais mais en même temps je trouve ça
satisfait pas un truc d'insatisfaction
chronique toi un petit démon intérieur
qui est lié à quoi tu sers peut mieux
faire
ça c'est ton parent ou ton prof qui est
dans un coin de sa tête qui dit non
parce qu'il ya des chaînes que tu
regardes les gentilles dit un jour
j'aimerais être heureux quand je serai
grand papa en france un forcément à bas
copains du web évidemment ouais je suis
à fond lui il ya absolument tout le
cocktail d'humour absurde
il est hyper fort en montage en effets
spéciaux et où il raconte vachement bien
les histoires sorties peut aller
n'importe où on le suit oui certains
disent que c'est son métier
légende le raconte le visuel je sais
même pas s'il existe vraiment peut-être
juste qu'est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un c'est
la fête et soit alors
euh pas trop trop y en avait non mais ça
je suis moi je sais même pas j'aimerais
tu vas avoir cet aplomb et mesure plus
tard en fait c'est bon je me suis fait
mal mais c'est même à ça c'est que en
fait les beaucoup de youtube heures qui
ont plein de moyens et ou aux us en
particulier mais et où j'ai été
vachement déçu du traitement de leur
sujet tu vois pas ce qu'ils ont une
approche assez à l'américaine je
pourrais dire ce mot que c'est un peu
cliché mais tu vois genre il ya beaucoup
de défis d'effets de manche quoi ils
sont en moi plein les yeux et en fait tu
te rends compte d'ailleurs que la
réflexion n'est pas vraiment poussé là
où tu me décaler ou pas vraiment à fond
était un peu ça super et c'est pour ça
que maintenant j'ai un gros taureau
youtube français où je trouve qu'on a
quand même des gens qui écrivent bien
ils ont pas les moyens de faire de la
mise en scène de l'espace où ils n'ont
pas forcément la même culture de l'image
elle sauf que dans l'écriture
meiway chez nous je trouve qu'on est on
est plutôt pas mal loti avec david loix
preuves viviane syllabus truc incroyable
à chaque fois
ouais c'est vrai que benson a ce côté
plus scolaire eh ben on va quand même
allé un peu poussée des trucs là bas
parce que parce que justement background
académique
non je pense pas qu'on vainement sa puce
envie de faire des trucs sur le terrain
et tout ouais enfin on a fait pas mal
déjà
ouais mais j'aimerais bien faire de
trucs sur le terrain qu'ils sont
tu as gardé le côté on parle de sujets
qui dépassent le terrain future place
d'un truc qui tue sur place tu vas
trouver un truc qui va te permettre de
dérouler sur un sujet qui est très large
qui pourrait en tout cas ça j'aimerais
bien faire ça parce que je trouve ça un
peu ce qui manque
l'alliance des deux quoi mais quitte à
le faire sur des formes assez bon et toi
d'ailleurs tu voudrais pas si on me
donne l opportunité dont il va faire un
truc genre à la télé ou netflix signal
fixe te propose un truc tu dis ouais je
sais pas franchement repartir sans fin
partir sur un gros projet comme ça déjà
moi j'aime bien je sais faire des
petites vidéos coup par coup
après je suis pas contre aller sur le
terrain ça vraiment parce que la
géologie c'est vraiment trop con de
rester dans ma chambre c'est pas du tout
ma chantôme bibliothèque ouais c'est ça
alors que bon l'intérêt c'est d'aller
voir les quelques doigts couverts
semblant vrai et tout enfin il ya moyen
de faire des trucs géniaux sûr je pars
en antarctique et sur un glacier elle
est sur un volcan enfin tu veux c'est un
peu con reste un an je serai trop stylé
même peut-être géologue de terrain ou en
fait tu fais de l'expédition
voilà un caillou quoi c'est génial
j'adorerais j'adorerais faire des trucs
d'expédition comme ça mais c'est un bon
temps dans mon cas ça a l'air très clair